Herbs and they moved shit around and put
things in weird places and when you read
the translation like what the fuck does
this mean?
Well they're figuring out how to
translate it.
Not just both word for word,
but figuring out how you would say that
same sentence in English structure as
well.
Yeah.
So it's clear what you know,
what you're translating.
It's fucking fascinating shit man.
It's fascinating.
And I also
wonder after,
you know,
50 or so years of everybody using
English on the Internet,
how many kids are gonna grow up just as
English as their,
you know,
their new language and the original
languages,
like the old fashioned thing their
parents did.
Could you imagine if there was only one
language,
could you imagine how much shit would
get done?
Can you,
you know what's interesting though,
when you say that,
like imagine languages are going to go
away by technology.
Very,
very,
very fast.
Old Languages.
Well,
so what's going to happen?
Like translate on motto,
like you have to sit there and have
something translated to you in pr in
real time.
You know it's going to be voice
detection and everything like that,
so it's going to make language.
Languages though people are still gonna
want a traditionalist,
so we'll still be there playing with
their whole thing.
But what if a few generations go by,
right?
I think things are going to change.
Well,
you're a proponent of the isolation
tank.
You actually have.
John Lilly's tank don't do actually is
pretty cool.
I met John.
He gave me his tanks.
You and my only other friend that ever
had one that's having Willie mays is
fucking baseball bat,
you know,
it's cool.
I've got to shower shoes to go with it.
Oh,
I actually get out and walk and issues.
Every time I go from my high heels are
pretty boring.
Brown shower shoes.
But imagine when they figure out how to
stimulate the mind to create certain
states and they do it in conjunction
with the tank,
which is really the way to do it because
it eliminates all the sensory input from
this world.
If they could figure out how to do that,
put some electrodes on your head and set
you and that fucking tank and light you
up like a Christmas tree and you just go
into some other world,
then maybe people will stop.
I think Dr Lilly did that to me with one
CC ketamine injected,
you know?
Yeah.
You told me about that.
What a rush.
What did he do exactly?
Well,
when I got there,
actually they,
I was going to go into the tank just
straight and um,
when I got to rinse off and everything
before you go in the tank and the guy
was prepping me and he says,
you know,
usually when we do it,
we go in with one CC,
injected in a muscularly,
you know,
ketamine,
would you like some?
And I hear part of my brain go,
no,
no drugs.
Thanks.
And then I hear my mouth go,
oh,
absolutely.
I'd love some.
And then I,
I felt like a complete third person in
my own reality because he said,
no problem,
you know,
it's injected into muscularly.
Is that a problem in my side of my brain
went needles?
No,
my mouth,
however went,
no problem.
That'd be great.
You want to friend them and,
and you know,
and I,
and he walked away to go get me this
stuff.
And I stood there for a minute and my
brain was saying no way.
And my other side of my brain went,
look,
you're a doctor.
Lily's house,
man,
you've come all this way.
There's no way you're saying no.
And uh,
he walked back in and I felt a little
alcohol swab and my muscle and I heard
my brand go no.
And then I heard my mouth go.
Thank you very much.
And uh,
and then,
uh,
I made the most naive.
Sorry,
sorry.
How long does it take to kick in?
And I will never forget his face when he
went,
oh,
you haven't done it before.
Oh,
you should lay down about 45 seconds a,
any like put me in the deck.
And uh,
when you do it,
what if you do something like that?
You have sleep apnea.
Do you run the risk of like choking and
not.
And not breathing,
uh,
I don't know,
I didn't have slept sleep apnea,
but the last thing I was thinking about
was sleeping when he slipped me into
that tank.
I thought I was there to watch the
entire world coming to an end.
And um,
I had a ringside seat was pretty
interesting.
So they shot you up with is ketamine,
you lie down on the tank and into the
tank and you float.
And for me it was the first experience
ever float.
And then when you first experienced
floating was with ketamine,
you know,
how do you say no to Dr Lilly?
You know,
I'd watched the movie altered states
dozens of times.
I'd own the laser disc.
That's how it happened.
What happened after you?
After you,
it kicks in 45 seconds.
I thought I was freaking out and I'm,
the funnier side of this was my good
friend was in the,
in the other room and I was background
noise while all this was going on.
And he didn't know about the ketamine
entering into the equation.
And he was sitting there with Dr
Lillian,
his assistant at the time,
Craig.
And um,
they had no concern of me like sounding
like I'm drowning.
And finally he asked,
you know,
did,
is he on Ketamine?
And uh,
and Craig said yes.
And he said,
would you go get me some?
And my friend was totally blown away.
I didn't think that was going to be the
answer to the,
to the problem.
And John put some ketamine into his leg
and told my friend to have a nice night.
And he went into his bedroom and my
friend could see into the bedroom where
the tank was next to a bed and he didn't
touch the tank.
He just went in and laid down next to
the bed.
And I actually stopped screaming at that
point.
And my friend was looking in,
the bedroom was screaming.
I was freaking out,
man,
I'm losing my mind.
So you're in the tank,
you pan it,
you start screaming,
John Lilly says,
I'll send me some of what he's having.
Yeah.
And honestly for me,
I felt like a,
well when I stopped screaming,
I remembered it was conscious.
I,
it felt like somebody came into my trip
and just said,
Yo,
take a deep breath,
calm down,
and,
and I was like,
okay,
and uh,
and you know what?
I just channeled the energy and it
actually was a really positive
experience.
John Lilly joined you and your trip.
What if he joined you in the actual
isolated did it?
Me and my girlfriend later on tried to
get it.
It's like that dentist,
not a cool place for to have a friend
Sasha here.
Let's cuddle.
It didn't work,
but you know what?
In a sense,
yes.
I feel like he did.
I felt like there was a telepathic
communication as much as this is going
to blow all of the credibility I just
had about talking about pot.
Yeah.
I actually felt like Dr.
Liliana communicated on a level that was
more telepathic during
the time I was under the drug.
Do you think like the tank even horror
story?
Don't want to believe it.
I don't even work though.
If he took the same amount of pills and
just lay down or something.
The tank that no,
no pill or I wouldn't think that your
involvement with the tanks,
you know,
here's how Mckenna described ketamine.
He said that it was like you.
He believed that when you did
psychedelics,
you somehow or another connected to the
experience that everybody had had doing
those psychedelics before you.
That's one of the reasons why the
mushroom experience so rich and diverse.
It says some thousands and millions of
people over the years have done
mushrooms and you're connected to this
one big gigantic growing experience.
He said,
doing ketamine.
He said Ketamine is so much more rare.
That really it gave him the feeling like
he was in an abandoned warehouse or an
office building with no furniture in it.
That's interesting.
Yeah.
You said was very alone in my trip
initially and then when I felt like
there was another energy around me,
I,
I.
It did feel different and it was weird.
I had a long conversation with John
Lilly after and he really,
he was.
I really liked the old guy who was
really a nice guy and then afterwards
when I left,
whatever,
the next day his assistant showed them,
said,
you made a real impression on John.
He'd like you to have his tank.
He just gave it to you.
Yeah,
that's crazy.
You probably felt bad.
He probably didn't want you to sue them
for fucking whacking them with ketamine
and throwing them into a fucking
bathtub.
He's like,
this dude might sue me.
It was going to work this.
I'm going to work this on the stroke it.
I'm going to call them up until Yo,
man,
you,
you are the shit.
I don't want to give you my take.
You know?
Oliver Stone went the night before me
and his tank and a 400 vps in the shit
over stones.
A big pooper.
Never really thought about that until
just this minute.
I would have definitely ended up into
those.
Yeah,
we both did it.
Yeah.
We got to talk about it.
Years later,
him and I sit down and chat about a
weekend at John's.
Wow.
What a fucking freaky dude.
John blow out with her with a special k
and throw him into a fucking pink of
water.
Do No,
this is the guy that the day of the
Dolphin was made about.
He's the guy that did all of the
research books.
All of them.
He's a bad motherfucker.
He was awesome.
He's got a great book where he actually
shows it's got the deep self,
has directions on how to make a tank.
Shows you how to make that precursor.
The son of Mario Tech.
I got,
isn't it Santa Maria is somebody's son.
Somebody's.
Yeah.
That's what I had to.
I had one of those as well.
Now I got a float lab one.
The new.
A crazy version of or showed you that?
Not yet in the basement.
The trip.
Fucking.
It's the craziest thing.
I think they're awesome.
You know,
and I think a lot of people have never
really been able to meditate within
themselves.
And when you get into this tank and
there's no resistance on your body and
you can actually get really here and you
don't really see and you feel the same
temperature as the surroundings around
you,
you really field so boundless and it's,
it's truly flying through space.
You flying a spaceship,
man,
that is a portal to another world.
It really is.
It really is how to relax.
Once you learn how to relax and it takes
a few times.
You have to do it a bunch of times and
depending on your personality,
how good you are truly letting go.
But if you really learn how to let go,
man,
you go on trips in that thing.
I used to,
I used to set an alarm at like 4:00
AM.
If I went to sleep before midnight and I
just walk because I had mine in my
bedroom.
I've walked right into my tank,
back in it and like go back to sleep and
like four or five,
6:00,
I would always wake up before seven,
feeling like,
man,
I had just slept for so long and I felt
great.
And night dreams would be so lucid,
so incredibly real and tangible in a
holy shit.
I want to go write them down loose.
That's intense.
So you only walk a couple steps.
Barely woke up.
I barely up right back.
Right back out.
Got It.
It's awesome minds too far from our
fucking bird and the walking.
I'd wake up going,
oh,
what the fuck you doing with your life
Rogan kit number 4:00
in the morning.
You fucking were to go meditate.
And then I'll go on the internet and
check my twitter follows the congress is
what's going on here.
It will be an hour later.
I'd be like,
I'm going to get some breakfast,
man.
I'm fucking hungry.
Except in coffee.
Did you see that shit that was on CNN?
But are these,
these uh,
all these former US air force and
penalties are coming out about Ufo shows
around nuclear on nuclear facilities.
That's fucking trippy shit man.
I wonder if these guys are all just
nuts.
I wonder if these guys are all kooks or
if feel like disinformation guys that
work for the government.
The government wants us to think there's
fucking really ufos thing,
just distracted.
Meanwhile,
Obama's passing on his legislation,
making it any easier for people to wire,
tap your emails and get into your
fucking twitter account,
your facebook pages,
and they're passing all this legislation
right under everybody's nose.
I wonder if that's what it is.
I wonder if it's still so distraction
tactic.
I truly believe it is.
I mean they appointed the UN,
appointed some chick to be the
ambassador when the aliens come.
Listen Bitch.
You don't speak from.
Is that real?
Okay?
Yes.
The you can just at points.
Just sit around and wait.
She is a,
I believe she's an astrophysicist and
her job is to communicate with the
aliens.
You don't talk for me.
Hooker.
Can I just say something?
I got a dog.
We have been on this planet evolving
with dogs for thousands of years and we
don't speak Doberman.
We don't speak German shepherd and how
do we think that they're going to show
up and suddenly we're going to be like
sit good alien up,
up your idea and they want a snack.
Is that they're going to be so much more
intelligent than us.
They're going to be able to understand
what our language is.
They'll be able to decipher our
language.
That's the hope and the dream.
I think they're going to show up and
think,
food,
man.
You look soft and juicy.
Well,
what we do is if you look these people,
if you look at what you look at,
what do they appreciate us?
We'd be like cows.
You know?
If you look at what every single
intelligent life form on this planet
does,
they're gonna.
Make sure that they explored everything
weaker than that.
That's the ethic of space.
It seems like there's the ethic of life
on this earth,
on this planet is survival of the
fittest.
It's
and when you're the fitness,
you get to fuck the ones who are not as
fit.
That's just the way it is.
Why human beings do to dolphins and sea
world and what we do to killer whales.
We know the killer whales rescue human
beings that fall off boats.
We know that there's never been a case
in the wild of a killer whale documented
case.
Killing a human,
the only time they've ever done it then
see,
well,
that's the only time I've ever done it
is in capital.
And we know what dolphins do.
Dolphins killed baby dolphin so that
they can force the female dolphins.
Dolphins are ruthless.
Is that true as fuck as true,
that they killed the baby hill?
The babies,
how do they kill them?
Kill Them.
Their face.
Are they kill them?
Yeah.
And that's one of the reasons.
Yeah,
the dolphins raped the fuck out of each
other too.
And one of the reasons why female
dolphins are horace is female dolphins
are super slutty and the reason being is
because they have to fuck as many male
dolphins as possible so that when they
have babies,
those male dolphins won't kill the
babies.
So the male dolphin will go,
I could be mindset,
might be mine.
Damn the liker because they,
they get the Fucker,
this documentary.
And so the,
um,
the,
uh,
the idea being that the mother does not
breed while she's with the baby.
So it takes like six years or something
like that before she's going to breed
again.
Oh,
before she breeds,
because before she breeds again,
because she has to take care of the
baby.
How old?
How long does it
and lift?
That's a good question.
I don't know.
I don't know,
but you need to know a lot about sex
life,
dolphins.
The thing about fucking one of those for
awhile,
if it only had a sheep's pussy,
but it was a dolphin,
put those two together.
You get pocket and if you drag you
through the water at the same time,
take you on trips,
you going 40 miles an hour,
it'd be able to hold your breath.
Goddamn.
There'll be going to need to design some
new dolphin.
They can.
Fuck.
That's right.
Or maybe you could just climb on the
back of a dolphin and just get a
flashlight attached to the dolphin.
That could be.
I heard it already feels good.
There's videos on the Internet.
People fucking dolphins.
Have you seen this?
No.
That can't be right.
That's totally real.
No one's fucking dolphins do it.
Possible.
Huh?
The penis comes out and the woman gets
underneath it.
Or remember it was you making the shop.
Now I'm not,
now there's videos,
kinds of videos that people fucking dog
therapy time,
actual sex.
Brian,
I need.
I need some clarification on.
Okay.
We need to.
We need to go deep on this one story.
We can't just leave people out there
thinking that there's not many people
are right now going,
this is bullshit.
I was looking at myself.
A lot of people.
That's the beautiful thing about the
Internet.
Now instantly you could find out.
You can google and at least get the
general consensus.
I mean,
you can't find out who killed Kennedy.
There's some shit that you can't find
out,
but you can google.
Yes.
On 19.
Yeah.
Help us win in California.
Thirty short days away.
Prop.
Yeah,
it's.
Yes.
On [inaudible] dot com.
Thirty four days away.
And what are the most recent polls?
Recent polls show us winning.
Oh,
it depends on who's pulling.
You look at Fox or what have you.
And a while they make very human sounds.
And Brian,
he's looking at.
Don't tell them it's not real.
It's not real apple.
Dolphin uniform.
Apple.
Is it good to let you look at porn?
Yeah,
man.
How you think you're going to look at
that on that?
They're going to take no dolphin porn.
No good.
Yeah,
but they can't stop you from going all
those,
uh,
those websites.
Now they will go to html fire because of
the IPAD.
All the porn websites,
they,
none of them were flat base anymore
until like,
oh really?
You can't get on the IPAD.
Oh,
let's just change this shit up.
So on,
change everything in html five.
And then that works on your ipad and
then you can watch porn on your ipad.
Who would have known innovation leading
the way?
Again,
it's porn leading the way.
There are a lot of Christians who need
their porn.
They do you know.
How about that new dude?
The guy busted.
What's his name?
Eddie Long.
So his name,
the new big bangs.
Preacher boy.
What is his name?
Dude,
that's double bad because you know,
brothers and is supposed to be even
thinking like brothers did not get no
homo man.
That's the proposition.
Eight passed in California.
A lot of gay people were really pissed
off at black folks.
Black folks voted some ridiculous
number.
Hey,
this percentage,
white folks should be mad at that
Christian siblings who brought
Christianity to all these poor people,
you know,
because that's really the problem.
Okay,
well you're going fake with moral a
little bit far with your blame there
fella.
Whoa.
What is this guy's name?
Ed Long.
What was the guy's name?
Busted.
I want to read this online due to be
added long.
That's like as right to to this size of
the dolphins.
Dick,
the best way you can have sex with a
male doctor in this.
The masturbator Brian male to his name
is Eddie Long.
It's true.
Eddie long right?
This fiction,
you really couldn't man.
It's like you remember when that was a
long name.
You know it,
right?
Here's the best part.
Homies got a pink tie.
Oh,
how about that?
So he's the one taking it.
Yeah.
We're watching it.
Not necessarily with the pink.
Tie this off.
Yeah,
I'm right here.
Everything else is black outfits.
Dark and strong.
Powerful.
He just said,
you know,
I'm into that boy pussy.
Well,
bringing the flashlight.
This is.
This is a big ad.
Yeah,
they're good at it.
Kept it ads.
They saying,
fuck your Tivo.
I know that's like the only time I ever
watch as now or what?
I'm trying to watch a youtube clip or
CNN.com.
Hey,
you know what man,
it's only 30 seconds whenever.
Well of my life added up.
So this guy,
this Ed,
Eddie Long,
another Christian man in a position of
power that it turns out was actually
banging boys.
Shocking.
What if,
what if?
What if like the Catholic church has
been run by gays who were angry at the
straight people this whole time,
right?
And they get to wear their dresses and
have their fabulous cars and they drink
out of the cold chalices and be covered
and all these colors and live in total
secrecy.
And then pick out the little gay kid
right out of the straight audience.
Is that dating kate?
Madonna.
Whoa.
What do you mean the church hate
Madonna?
You know,
gay people love Mcdonald's.
Mcdonald's.
So that's for your analysis does not
hold it.
I think it's true.
That's what you think it is.
It's an ancient gay cult salts pope
wearing the dress.
Yeah,
of course.
Cow.
What's up with that crazy fish head?
All of them at the Vatican at.
Let me think.
I don't want to fuck women.
I want to go live with men for the rest
of my life.
Pretty much.
You get and you're not even allowed to
masturbate.
Why don't just,
Oh,
nocturnal admissions.
Well,
you can't even dream about getting off,
but how about Saul?
Peter?
That's shit they give them to keep them
from getting horny.
That's not true.
It's not real.
It's an urban myth.
Pretty much.
It's an urban myth,
but they still didn't actually give it
to them and stuff.
I think.
No,
I don't think it might be in jail all
the time.
There's always this.
Well,
Peter in the food really?
I don't know.
Whatever.
Uh,
I can't say I still dream of my
girlfriends and wake up feeling a
failure.
Rousy they're really assault Peter in
jail.
That's one of those urban legends type
things.
But urban legend,
the whole idea is ridiculous.
The whole idea that anybody would ask
you to not have sex.
Like why would God give me a deck if I
didn't want to use it?
God don't procreate,
go,
God does.
Not only does he not want you to
procreate,
doesn't want you to feel affection,
doesn't want you to love someone that
talks about,
you know,
there's no evolution.
There's just creationism.
They don't want to talk about incestual
relations between Adam and eve and all
your kids.
Yeah.
What the fuck that come from God.
Show up and get with the new boat.
Hey,
I got new.
Fresh,
fresh.
There you go,
brother.
Sisters fucking like crazy.
That would be what it had to be,
wouldn't it?
If you go with the Christians and then
they did all this in 6,000
years.
So what's up?
You're my brother.
What's a Christian brothers?
Don't eat that apple watch is bad.
You know,
and you know,
don't listen to a union.
That was the first prohibition
prohibition of Thou shall not eat from
the tree of knowledge.
And,
and who was the big cop,
right?
God.
How many people to two people he had to
police and God,
according to Christian mythology
couldn't handle prohibition.
Yeah.
How alertness is a god would make some
shit that he didn't want you to eat.
You don't eat it.
I'm telling you I will fuck your world
up.
Oh,
you ate the apple that I told you not to
eat.
Well,
guess what?
You don't ever get a second chance.
You're fucked forever.
Your whole species is fucked.
Joe.
Do you ever wonder if that's.
Do you wonder if that snake,
that one snake,
the original snake ever made it?
If he made it on Noah's Ark,
do you ever think about that?
Like no one does.
That snake was.
The devil wasn't really that much.
I know.
I was just like,
I was hoping that snake made it.
Maybe that snake is all around us all
the time.
Yeah,
pretty much.
The whole idea that,
you know,
they'll make fun of fucking Muslims or
that they'll make fun of scientologists.
They'll make fun of,
you know,
like,
well they've got the wrong thing.
You know,
we to come to Jesus.
Let's see.
I argue that everybody's an atheist
because a Jew doesn't believe in a
Christian God and the Christian God
doesn't believe in Buddha and the Buddha
doesn't believe in the Jewish God and
none of them believe in Mohammed.
So it's really,
they're all atheists because they don't
believe in anything,
but they're little fantasy truthfully.
So they're all atheists to somebody
else's shit to
somebody else's shit.
They don't believe in their other gods.
So Bam,
suddenly we're in alignment.
I just don't also believe with any of
their gods.
It's amazing that there are so many
different religions.
Hundreds.
Literally,
we were new.
We were lost.
We needed direction.
We need someone to walk up and go where
the food is.
I know where you'll be warm.
I know how to heal you sick when you die
and come with me.
It's amazing that there's so many
different religions,
but even though we know that they all
say different shit,
everyone is willing to die believing
that the one they believe is right.
Even though there's so many examples of
contradicting ideas for whatever fucking
reason.
We compartmentalize that when we,
you know,
go down the road of being a mormon or go
down the road of being a Catholic or a
baptist,
we just don't look at it.
Just don't just say this is my team and
screw your a team.
And it's a very and 10 fl mentality,
you know,
Rah Rah,
my team.
You're a team.
It's all the same shit.
It is all the same shit.
When I was in Indiana,
I was in Indiana for UFC.
Anybody who fought somebody from
Indiana,
even if they were American,
they would boo them.
Realize you're not from Indiana.
That's a local boy hoosiers.
But think about Indiana is great,
don't get me wrong,
but at the,
the mentality is so fucked up that your.
You're booing against other Americans
because they're not from a similar
place.
They're not within a certain distance of
where you sleep.
So you're there.
You don't even like them right now,
who's going up against a guy like we
need?
We don't just have Americans versus the
rest of the world will go down to
neighborhoods,
will break.
We'll break it down to neighborhoods.
We'll break it down to the hatfields and
mccoys.
The problem with Indiana is that there's
nothing else to fucking do there.
And they're not known for much in
Indiana.
And so that movie hoosiers came out,
everyone was like,
sports is now our big thing.
So now it's like seriously came out
because sports is a big thing.
Right,
right,
right.
But,
but they're so proud of that movie and
that because that's all they have kind
of living in Indiana to have this thing
called the Indianapolis 500.
That was kind of rights.
Do they have a lot of shit dude?
Yeah.
So it's fair to bring farming back to
the midwest is what we gotta do.
We gotta really farming.
You bring it back to him.
We need him,
man.
Well I know farm aid right now is in its
25th year in.
The problem with it is 25 years and
they've gotten were because all these
people they're trying to convince,
they've built their,
their,
their farms on corn and cotton are
completely wrong and they're not gonna
have any economic independence back
until they get there.
John Cougar Mellencamp came onto the
screen and they booed him really?
In Indiana from India.
He is the cue card.
He's a liberal liberal fucking real low.
It was crazy.
He showed them.
I expected everybody to go ape shit.
Wow.
Move.
You know,
in Ohio the farms are getting so bad
that they're like closing farms left and
right,
that a lot of the farms are turning into
shopping centers where my mom lived just
in five years,
used to be farms everywhere and now it's
like commercial buildings and they're
just,
they're losing all these farms because
there's no money in it or something's
not going on.
Right,
right.
At,
in the farming industry in Ohio,
well there's,
it's very difficult to run a farm and
make a profit.
It's incredibly difficult.
It's so fucking
hard,
especially when you're up against unfair
trade practices in fucking fuels that
come from 9,000
miles away.
How about c?
Do you know you don't even own your
seeds when you're a farmer,
when you
big deal and you know what hemp is the
one thing that we need to really push
that we don't have gml control of.
We have to stand up and ask for a,
you know,
our civil rights back.
We have to demand them and back.
In fact,
I mean,
when we.
When the seeds thing though,
what I was saying is when you buy seeds,
if you're a farmer,
you buy these seeds that have been made
by this company.
Monsanto.
Yeah.
You don't own those seeds.
You Go,
you got those seeds and when you plant
your new plants and you grow,
like save you grow peppers,
you can't take the seeds out of those
peppers and grow more peppers
because you don't own that.
You don't own that.
They'll sue you in copywritten.
If it is,
it's incredible.
Monsanto has actually people that go
around and test crops of people that
they suspect are using a generation away
from their last seat and it's really
scary.
I mean,
and you know crazy is that we take those
seeds and like make new new versions of
that seed.
It can't trace of it.
No.
Is that medically modified so they know
the genome of this particular plant that
they've created is.
So if you have that shit in your field,
you have to pay them every year.
Every year you have to pay for new
seeds.
You can't do the way people always did
it.
You grew tomatoes,
you took the seeds from the tomatoes
mode tomatoes,
they can't,
you can't do that.
Now.
It's illegal,
but data is the nuttiest shit ever,
and that's the number one reason for
Jimmy genetically modifying food is to
control the market.
And that's the number one reason.
Also why marijuana will always remain
illegal to a lot of people there.
They'll want to keep it illegal rather
is because I can't control it.
No,
you know,
hemp is grown in every industrialized
country other than America.
It amazing.
How crazy is that?
Canada right up north,
right above us,
right?
They're growing it.
They grow all of the seed products that
are in whole foods and all that.
Nutrition.
So all this is money that farmers could
be making this shit.
All this shit.
They're stealing from them.
These cons,
the government is stealing from them.
Steve Miller,
Julie,
and it's dealing it by denying them
their culture.
Fucking best country.
There's going to Indiana,
they're going to bomb California is what
they're gonna.
What are they going to do that
proposition nine takes over 19,
19,
proposition 19 thinking gay.
It's running when the,
um,
when they,
when that shit goes into effect,
if and when it's going to change the
culture,
it's kind of,
that's the big change is going to be in
people's behavior because you can talk
all the paper you want,
but what was the most fascinating thing
to me is what it does to people
socially.
It changes the fuck out of human beings,
right?
Well,
you know,
some of the things people are coming out
against prop.
Nice 19 to saying is that it's going to
lend itself to corporations and it's not
true.
Corporations are not saying that.
Who's saying that?
Well,
believe it or not,
we have a lot of people that are in the
medical marijuana industry that don't
want to see prop 19 past because they're
comfortable right now and they're
profiteering and they don't want to see,
you know,
a status quo change.
And it's really sad because these are
the people that would benefit the most
when they're local communities allow
them to start selling to anybody over 21
without a doctor's note.
Right?
But the doctors who've been making their
living for all these years,
given away prescriptions and charged 150
bucks a pop,
that's the source of income these guys
have.
That's where historically wealthy and
they'll do fine.
Actually practicing medicine,
I'm sure maybe,
but when you're set up for years and
years and years,
just given out medical marijuana
prescriptions and you're comfortable
with it,
then all sudden something's going to
come along to make your business go
away.
You're going to have to come up with
some whole new business,
but if you're a selfish douche bag,
I could see where you'd be like,
man,
I don't want this.
Isn't that why the alcohol beverage
industry is giving to the campaign
against us?
Isn't that why all these interested self
interested companies are stepping up?
Some kids,
you don't expect it out of the medical
marijuana doc.
Another lie heard was that big tobacco
moneys behind this when it's such
bullshit proposition 19.
Yes.
When you can look up and see where all
the money came from,
it it realistically,
the prop 19 was passed by somebody that
has somebody I've known for over 15
years.
He's a really good person that really
just wanted to do the right thing.
He wanted to put forward a more liberal
PR initiative,
but he had cash and he pulled the
initiative and he found that more
liberal initiatives.
We're not polling well enough to
actually pass,
so we actually pulled back,
pull back,
pull back on the verbiage until the gun
initiative that polled well enough to
pass and what a lot of people don't
realize is that this is not the means to
the end.
This is just.
Or this is a means to the end.
It's not the end.
It's just one small step in the
evolution of getting our freedoms back
and this prop 19 is going to be one step
closer to having our rights back and
what a lot of people aren't talking
about,
which is pissing me off,
is that we got meg whitman buying her
way into the governorship and we have
Steve Cooley who has been the guy down
here in la.
For those of you who don't live in La,
who has been closing down all the Los
Angeles pot clubs,
and if this guy gets the top cop
position in the state of California and
prop 19 loses all of these idiots and
I'll say you are idiots that are going
against prop 19 that are selling medical
marijuana,
are going to lose your businesses and
lose your freedoms and the only thing
that's going to protect you right now is
if everybody in the state gets the
rights that you have been getting for
the last 14 years since medical
marijuana concentrate on these dildos.
Let's concentrate on that.
Yeah,
let's try and concentrate on that cop.
What's the.
Yeah,
I'm sorry.
Steve Cooley is.
This is the guy that's running for
attorney general and he's basically
running it.
Somebody that's against the death
penalty and in California you might as
well be running,
get somebody on a post running against
someone who's against the death penalty.
Yes.
Oh,
so he's running unopposed in that sense.
He is.
Absolutely.
And when he gets in,
his agenda is to do in the state,
but he has already done in La.
Well why's he want to shut down medical
pot stores ideologically and who knows
what,
who knows what he's invested in,
who knows what his reality is from those
campaigns,
how to his life,
you know,
who knows who,
who,
who really he's loyal to in that sense.
You know,
but there's something,
there's some campaign contributions or
something.
There's something going on.
I would love to be able to find it,
follow the money forensically and see
exactly where it came to these people
because in some ways there's got to be
strings pulling them,
you know,
and it's not cheap to run a campaign in
the state of California.
You need to get on the side to people
with a lot of money.
That's where don't have a lot of that
money that she is very,
very rich.
And what is she?
What was her position in Ebay?
She had something to do with Ebay.
She,
I thought,
founded,
not founded.
She was the one that was brought in and
brought them from being a very small
company to a very large company.
She helped organize them and she rode
their growth curve.
Okay,
so she made a ton of money off Ebay and
now she wants to be the governor and
she's spending how much money to do this
already.
Spent over 100 million dollars of her
own money to become governor of
$100,000,000
for a job that pays 200,000
a year.
Google it people much as pay.
It's pays nothing.
And,
and this is the scarier part.
It's like,
what do you think she's going to
accomplish with this hundred million
dollar influence?
What is she doing this for?
A testament to their ego.
You know,
it's building a big,
you know,
don't do it too.
And you know,
this is just turned my volume down.
No,
this is the part that kind of bothers me
is that this is more of what we've had
for a long time.
It's just that now we're looking at it
and were grossed out by it,
but don't think before newspapers and
Internet carried the word that robber
barons weren't running politics going
back to the thirties and forties and
fifties.
And when,
when I say they,
I don't mean to sound like some
conspiracy nut.
I mean to sound like somebody that's
realistic about the fact that alcohol
got together after prohibition and went,
Yo,
who's our competition?
Oh,
these kids are smoking this local weed
out a psa and then they really should go
after talking to this way.
Okay.
This is Meg Whitman woman.
She is obviously very wealthy.
Um,
so it's going to be very difficult to
buy a person who's very wealthy.
She very wealthy.
So why would this very wealthy person
want to stop medical marijuana in
California?
Because that is what she wants to do.
What would be her motivation?
Because it would not be financial,
right?
She doesn't need the money.
She's spending 100 million dollars.
Can I say governor?
You don't think that the alcohol
companies for sure and not giving her
$100,
million million,
killing.
You have that much money,
Joe,
it isn't sitting in a locker at the edge
of your bed.
It's sitting in investments and I'd love
to know what her portfolio is invested
in because she has people that are
actually standing there saying,
this is what I'll advise you to do,
and anybody that's advising somebody
that has literally hundreds of millions
of dollars vested way is going to say,
listen,
this initiative is bad for your liquor
investments.
It's bad for your pharmaceutical
It's bad for a financial decision on her
part.
A lot of why we're dealing with
prohibition and why we're dealing with
people that are against it is because of
the financial connections they have in
the more wealthy they are,
the more that people lean against them.
How?
How few?
In a sense do we have a view?
Because here you are a guy that made it
in TV.
Five years of Newsradio,
five plus years on fear factor.
You have a career.
You will have advisors around you
saying,
listen Joe,
if you do stupid stuff,
it's going to knock it you the big jobs
that will pay a lot of money and then
I'm not going to make money.
So where those Pearson's going to advise
you to go be the activist that you've
become?
Are they going to say,
Bro?
Really?
Because I know that a lot of other
actors have to stop and think,
man,
I won't get hired if,
if I start getting all radical and
that's what they really believe.
So they towed the line.
You are so rare because you haven't told
the line.
He said,
fuck it.
I'd rather be happy and be myself than
be some slave to a corporate,
you know,
dictation.
Yeah,
well you don't have to do it that way.
Those guys are pussies.
A lot of them are.
But when you're a nice person,
but how few woody Harrelson's and Joe
Rogan's do we have speaking up for the
right reasons.
Um,
well,
you know what?
A lot of people have families and they
want to play it safe and they feel
conservative and they get paranoid and
they don't trust in the greater good of
humanity and the people's ability to see
what they're saying.
They don't.
They don't have faith in their ability
to express themselves so that people
understand the point of view that they
have and where they're coming from.
I have confidence in my ability to
express myself and you do it for us all
in the way that's important for
everybody.
I think everybody should and would do
it.
If you're.
If you're a rational thinking person,
why would you live your life pretending
to be something other than who you are.
You know?
Why would you not want people to know
about something that's radically changed
the way you look at the world?
Why would you not want to?
Why?
Because fucking meg whitman says it's
bad.
We get that bitch.
Get the fuck.
Did she quit or get fired from Ebay?
I don't know because she's a woman who
wants to be in control of things.
It's always 75 percent of Ebay's
audience stone people in the middle of
night buying shit.
She shouldn't have her audience.
I don't know.
She probably pulled this airplane.
I got fired.
You know she's a slapped away.
Far more lucrative.
Creepy man.
Women don't want to run.
Shit creeped me out.
No,
I know it sounds gross,
but it's totally true.
Soundwise Hillary Clinton.
He doesn't.
She doesn't creep you out.
She is a creep me the fuck out.
Right?
But at least a rise of Condoleeza Rice
was running things.
When you think you'd freak the fuck out.
Creepy guys.
Dick Cheney came to.
I'm not saying I want guys running shit,
but at least they've been doing that
forever.
My older chick wants to hop in there and
compete with the men.
I'm like,
what are you crazy bitch?
What are you doing?
You're not balanced.
You ain't got no fucking Yogi.
You're not going to see through the
maze.
You're.
You're fucking just as crazy as the men,
if not crazier,
because you have to because you're a
woman and because they're going to prove
that they're tougher than the men
they're replacing.
That scares me.
I there was a moment where Hillary
Clinton was running for president when I
was thinking,
you know what?
She's going to win at.
What if she wins and she gets a new
position where one of these crazy fucks
from another country tests her because
she's a woman.
I mean if that political power is real
and that the president really has any
say,
and then anybody in another country
really does pay attention to them,
that it's not all this big,
gigantic build a burger meeting group.
Assuming that a president is real,
could you imagine what Putin would do if
he sat across from fucking Hillary
Clinton or salar Pailin at a.
it's some sort of a.
it's horrible.
He would crush them,
isn't a mock them.
He would.
Most cultures put their most
intellectually capable people in power
and not their best idiots.
It's just,
it's not that.
It's not that men should be running shit
right.
It's not.
It's the most capable bit of the alpha.
The one,
the idea of having a leader is fucking
ridiculous.
I think it's an archaic shit that we
have to figure a new way around,
so I'm not saying that men should be
running shit.
Anybody who was a woman that wants to
run shit,
like that's kinda crazy.
Like you don't even have a dick.
Why are you trying to control
everything?
What are you doing?
Why are you trying to fucking grab the
reins?
What do you do it?
I don't want to be president.
Okay.
I'm not.
I don't want to be a leader.
I'm don't get me wrong.
I'm not saying that I am better than a
woman who would be doing the job.
I'm saying when I see a woman who wants
to be a leader,
I understand the man wanting to be a
leader.
It makes sense to me.
Even if I don't believe in it or agree
with it.
I understand it.
When I say a woman is wanting to do it,
I'm like,
look at that crazy bitch.
That's what I think.
I think you want to be the king of the
world and you're a chick.
Whoa.
You know?
But yet,
Iceland's not in wars and they had a
female froze.
I was thinking of all that female
leaders around the world.
I'm like,
there's a lot.
I totally sexist.
It's totally sexist,
don't get me wrong.
But I don't think anybody should be a
leader.
I think the whole idea based on science,
it's based on some leftover fucking shit
from back when we were a tribe of 200
monkey people and we needed a leader to
protect us from the other monkey people
wanted to rape our women and take our
food.
I mean,
that's what it is.
The idea that one person can represent
the whole country,
like a president.
I don't give a fuck if he has a cabinet.
I don't give up the idea that there's a
one guy that stands there and gentlemen,
the president of the United States,
you know,
even the figurehead,
even if the descendant of royalty,
it's shirt and it's an Avatar,
that the whole idea is ridiculous.
It's,
it's,
it's so really created our whole
structure in America to compete against
what they were,
what they were fighting.
And then they became and they became
wayward,
right?
Wayward.
It's beautiful.
I love that.
I'm going to hear so much shit from my
female friends.
Well thank you.
Don't think women should be running
things.
Oh,
what does that mean?
I think men do it better.
Maybe.
Maybe might have been doing it wrong for
so long.
Maybe be good for a woman to give it a
try.
Like you're definitely comfortable in
your relationship.
That's a worldly thing to say.
If she's a woman,
meaning like,
I know what I mean.
I'm not going to be like,
yeah,
fuck women should be presidents now.
I'm like,
what was his name to be president?
What are you talking about?
He's saying he's afraid to get his dick
cut off when it goes home.
And he's obviously saying you're not.
So what he's saying is you misread he's
saying is he's trying to pretend to be
someone different.
So he's attractive female race.
It is.
I'm not a bashing that females rate.
Listen,
most females,
the women that take that are constant
and not bashing the female racers.
I'm not bashing them male race.
It doesn't want to be president.
You know,
most of the male race doesn't want to be
president.
You don't want to be president.
It's not a male thing.
It's a leader thing,
but what I'm saying is I understand the
creepy fuck control freak men.
I understand that instinct,
but when I see a chick that wants a rock
that I go,
what's going on there?
Sarah Pailin.
I guess one way.
Sarah Palin's just his dummy that got
stuck into a nice position that she's
trying to make some money.
I mean,
that's really what it is,
but after awhile it's not that anymore.
After a while it's like,
well,
you're the figurehead for the retard
movement and you're just like them and
you got a microphone on you and there's
a spotlight on you and Oh,
now you're a fucking problem because you
never were supposed to get to this point
and send out.
You've artificially been inserted into
the public consciousness with no merit
and now all the retards go.
They rise up and start these fucking tea
party rallies.
Have you watched any of that shit?
Crazy God damn thing Glenn Beck is just
making gold underwear and gold socks and
diamond covered fucking cars from that
guy.
Must be just scraping it in with raikes.
She'll obviously fully shit too.
It's like his game only works on the DM.
It only put.
There's so many dumb people.
It's a very effective tactic.
Him and her together.
Men,
they scare the fuck out of double dumb
dumb.
Glenn Beck and Sarah Pailin.
They combined forces with the president.
Do they could.
They could run for president,
man.
That's real shit.
I hope that
presidents of black lady with a list and
that's totally a lesbian.
I hope it's like every single horrible
thing that's wrong with,
you know,
like banning gay marriage,
women presidents.
I hope it's all combined into one like
super president that just pisses off
everybody hope it's an alien,
an alien
alien winds than disguise of a human
being and then tells her buddy,
now that we have a deputy that we'd like
to know that I'm in place and I'm
running shit,
but just need to sit the fuck down.
We've been thinking about exterminating
you.
Fucks for about 50 years now.
I thought your concept of us being cold
was really accurate.
Well,
it is a giant life form.
It's a giant life form on a super
organism.
That's what the human race is.
The human race is on earth.
Earth is a life form.
It is a super organism.
You know?
We don't think of planets that support
life as a life form,
but because it's an environment where
life grows,
but I'm not so sure about that.
If you look at lava and the center and
the magnetic core and you look at the
magnetosphere and the atmosphere and
like this is not just a place where life
is.
It's almost like a system.
It's alive and well.
I don't know what's conscious man.
We're guessing and we assume that
conscious means that it can talk like us
and move like Gospel.
We don't know.
We don't.
There's a lot of evidence that there
might be something going on inside
trees.
Some sort of fucking a real reaction
that trees and plants have to pee.
People
will thank US cellular intelligence.
Yeah,
and that's really where we've always
thought,
oh,
it's in our brain,
and then there's this myth that we don't
even use our own brain,
all of our brain,
and it's like,
really?
Do you know how many of us are you
stupid that you believe that your whole
body's not actually it all,
all marks right now.
And I think that our capability of
intelligence is really,
really deep.
That's a metaphor.
I think for,
um,
wasted potential if people have this
idea that we're only using 10 percent of
our brains.
If we just really concentrate like that.
No one even knows what that means.
What does that mean?
You're only using 10 percent of your
brain.
What's going on with the other 90
percent of useful?
Well,
you know how we know how the brain works
when we blow holes and parts of the
brain,
we shoot people in parts of their head
and then gonna go,
oh,
I can't see anymore.
I guess that's the part where you see
out of it.
Oh,
we drill the hole here on Sundays.
Calm.
Well,
I guess this is the part that makes them
aggressive.
We'll just drill a hole in that,
but that's the law.
Bottomy.
That's what they did.
When people get a little nutty,
they go,
what do you wanna do you to kill him?
We want to drill a fucking hole in his
head and see if we can fix something.
One flew over the cuckoo's nest.
Yeah.
They would fix people by drilling holes
in their head.
Hollaback back.
Do you know you ever.
There's a whole group of humans that
voluntarily put holes in their head and
they believe that it alleviates pressure
and gives them euphoria and that the
pressure of the growing brain trapped
inside the skull causes headaches and
all sorts of problems,
and in Africa there's fucking cultures
that have done this where they
literally.
They caught the entire skull.
I posted it on twitter,
see if he can find it.
I mean,
I don't know what you would look under.
There's A.
There's a term for it.
There's a term for it for holes in where
they call shit.
I'm fucking up here because there's an
actual term for it,
but people do it on purpose.
It's like it's a.
it's a.
see if you can find that,
but people will fall interi holes and
panning.
Panning.
T R e p a n I n g itself,
near.
You'd sleep pressure beneath the
surface.
Yeah,
and there's,
there's a video of these African dudes
where they do it with no anesthesia and
they do it with these fucking stone
tools.
They like strip away your fucking
scalped and cut out your bone.
Oh,
they don't just do it once.
They do it as many as 20 times they
ended.
Yeah,
and they fucked their brains up.
Dudes are not only that though,
you'd have to wear it.
They have to wear hats from that I'm
sure.
Because their brain is exposed.
There's a like a canoe shape cutout on
the top of their fucking skull.
Dr John Clark with the first one to do
it in 16,
64 and he taught the Africans tend to do
it and that's what they're saying to us.
I'm sorry,
us us American.
Hmm.
Well he might've.
It might've been just like religion.
We brought Christianity over to Africa.
It just says first fits physician to
perform it in the US.
And he did it as a alleviating pressure
on someone.
Whoa.
It's like,
if you can think about it,
someone's out there doing it,
man.
You've seen those women in Surrey.
Is that.
Whereas in Africa where they cut their
lip and stick a plate in it.
Have you seen that shit?
You know what I'm talking.
You never seen the plates and the lips.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
I didn't know the theory to the named.
It's the most insane thing.
It's not just weird.
The bigger the plate,
the more cows they're worth when they
get married.
So like saying if you want to marry my
daughter,
okay.
And she's got a giant ass fucking plate.
I'm like,
bitch,
that was a 50 cal plate.
You've got to come strong sign.
Right?
So dudes would have to give her her.
They have to give up a herd because
she's willing to carry around this giant
plate in her lips.
What else?
Issue in their teeth out to.
They have to bang their lower teeth out
because the plate sits there and you
can't get a full plate in there if you
have the lower teeth.
So when the plate starts getting big,
they have to smash their teeth out.
You might blow jobs filled like probably
does Africa suck.
People willing to do that?
You're willing to put plates in your
lips and cut holes in your heading where
they stretch the neck out.
That's fucking crazy.
They must be so freaked out.
They got stuck in Africa.
They're like,
look,
we're going to make this interesting.
Right?
But here we are stuck running from
hyenas and getting eaten by crocodiles
and shit.
We're going to have to stretch our next
album,
Mike,
our next real big.
Well,
who knows why they do these things well,
how about those heads of.
They found in Peru where they stretch
their head out gigantic,
like a big alien head.
They did it to like a huge percentage of
the population.
They put boards in their heads and tied
them down and literally extended their
head.
You know,
and people were thinking,
well,
is this to emulate something,
is to emulate the gods.
All the Annunaki people like,
see this is evidence they were doing
this to try to emulate,
maybe not.
Because look at these Africans that
cutting the fucking holes in their lives
and stick and plates and they,
the dudes cutting the holes in their
heads and letting the air out,
you know,
they're not emulating anything.
They're just practicing medicine.
They're fucking nuts,
man.
People are nuts.
Well,
they're still kind of.
Numbers are trolling everyone.
He knows freaky.
The disease I had as a child I found out
in the mid eighties,
they stopped treating aggressively that
like more when I was in the seventies,
I was more a victim of fucking
chemotherapy and an elective surgeries
are not elective surgeries,
but surgeries that weren't needed and
radiation than I was of the actual
disease because they were practicing.
Well,
yeah,
you know,
it's fucked up to is the accent.
Histiocytosis x meant that the pathology
of the disease was unknown.
And when I first asked an adult,
you know,
where did my disease come from?
And they went,
we don't know.
And I was like,
wait,
who's we,
you and me?
Or like,
we like.
So what exactly is the disease history
of an overactive immune system isn't
site.
It's history.
Oh,
site history of cytosis x and it's an
overactive right,
like I would have too many white blood
cells and they would like in a sense
accumulate,
if you will.
And uh,
usually it was in like bone marrow and
areas like that and it creates like blow
out.
So like my,
my spine,
it blew out my arm.
It blew out my hip.
It blew out.
Would it get better if you got sick?
What do you mean?
Sick?
Got a cold?
No,
no,
think no.
Don't sees it all the time.
But it's funny as I don't really ever
get sick either.
I either have problems where like
obviously it was overgrowing,
you know,
in marrows and stuff or I'm always
healthy.
I went through prison five years.
I didn't get a cold.
Whoa.
Yeah.
And a crazy place.
Let me tell you,
but start looking toilets.
I don't like touching doors and shit
though.
I'm not a Germaphobe,
but I actually,
I'm careful.
People are gross.
Yeah.
People nose picking balls,
scratching ass.
Fucking wipe and just disgusting
fucking.
Which is why I always recommend you use
the tissue from the bathroom when you
opened the door to any public restroom.
Take mine open like a man.
Not if you've got to pull it with a man,
you have to twist it and pull it.
Usually you do actually use a piece of
that.
There's ways you can protect yourself.
And if we had hemp,
we can be using hemp towel.
Man,
you just have to clean it man.
We'll get some hemp flashlights,
which is why we have to vote yes on 19
the vote yes on 19.
It's very important and if you're one of
those people out there that goes,
man,
you're fucking annoying.
Unfortunately,
there's a lot of potheads are annoying.
You know,
most potheads lot of straight people.
Yeah.
Like most people,
a good percentage of people are
annoying.
And the reason being is because we do
not have a direction book on how to
properly live a healthy life and
healthy,
fun,
satisfying life.
You know,
we,
we live our lives based on myths and
Bullshit TV shows and movies and we have
this distorted perception of what this
fucking world is all about.
So most people with,
especially with the situation that we
have now,
the way our world is set up,
it's so easy for a moron.
Just drift through and be taken care of
every step of the way and yet have
opinions and yet be able to vote.
George Bush Jr.
Sarah pailin.
Man,
that'S way scarier than her,
than him.
Gary coleman.
He was a man.
Wow,
that's right.
I said it.
Gary coleman.
We could vote.
Yeah.
Angry as fuck.
I'd been angry too after his whole life.
You know,
the saddest Part of his life would not
have been when he was in the hospital.
Dead,
dying and is fucking crazy.
Ex wife takes a picture and sells it to
My over him,
like all strapped up with pipes and shit
dying in bed and she's right next to him
with his dead.
She did that yet.
Dead fucking rubber face.
Just like didn't have any emotion in her
eyes.
Nothing like up here he is,
he's dead and this is me.
I'm next to the dead guy.
that's horrible.
Oh,
it's gross.
Reprise that shit on like pads.
I'm pretty sure.
well,
I've never seen that.
It did not know she did that.
yeah,
that's pretty darn.
I'm learning.
Well you got saved even.
Huh?
Finger should usually I'd do.
You know,
I can't thank you enough for coming out
and support prop.
Nineteen minutes dude.
You know I enjoy the marijuana.
So of course I've got to support prop
19.
You know a lot of people that have been
really confused on what this really does
man.
And you know that's been a big problem
for us because I was talking about what
I'm saying.
Most people will.
You look at pot ads,
you think they're annoying,
right?
Really?
I'm finding I'm annoying right now
because I can't believe all these people
I was working around that we thought I
thought was working towards a common
goal and now working against it because
a lot of people were against prop 19.
That's what you're sayinG.
a lot of people are against prop 19.
Not for the right reasons,
either financial reasons,
financial reasons or inaccuracy,
how muCh most hippies are though.
Every time
I ever was hanging out with hippies,
they were trying to make money like
making profits and still now there's a
lot of the ideas,
a lot of non hippies that are just
commercially motivated.
THere's a bunch of people that have just
been in this industry in the last few
years since sb four slash 20 passed and
allowed for clubs.
They're trying to make money and right
now they think,
oh no,
you're going to change this and we like
this,
so please don't change this,
and that is really what we're up against
when it comes from the the enemy within,
if you will.
There's a lot of people that aren't
hippies.
They're opportunists.
They are.
I knoW a bunch of people that are in the
business idealism.
Oh yeah.
The people that own like dispensary's,
they're doing a purely for profit.
There's a lot of good ones.
Berkeley,
harborside.
They're all good.
There's a lot of good ones.
ProvIde something that's good.
Marijuana is good,
but there's a lot of people that you
wouldn't expect.
They're not like old dudes with gray
hair and ponytails right there.
They're younG dudes.
It looks like they're fucking doing
squats.
Prop 19 is gonna.
Make it so these people aren't having to
get away with it.
It's they're going to be able to serviCe
their neighbors who have a right to have
pot and everybody in.
The state's going to have a right to
grow pot and that's going to be a big,
big yeah,
so all these people that are selling it,
the shit's going to go under because no
one's going to need to buy it.
You can just grow your own.
So easy to see the prices drop.
Well thankfully you know radically and
profits are going to drop and right now
you know it's the liquor companies.
It's the biG drug cartels.
These are the people that are more than
willing to play exaCtly what I'm paying
right now.
Just keep making it just as good.
I'll pay just as you know,
there's always going to be thousand
dollar bottles of wine,
you know,
and there's going to be people that do
things with the high quality and grandma
could grow better than me for instance,
and you'll want grandma's pot over mine.
I Want to look like cheetos.
I wanted to see like,
let's see.
Hi.
Of I just been throwing out my window is
that it doesn't.
It doesn't really lend itself for
quality with quantity because when you
have large amounts of it,
you don't have in a sense is as good a
quality control right now in smaller
batches.
Now let's talk about one thing for the
nonsmoking non marijuana smoking amongst
us.
This is one of the things that reallY
fascinated me the most when I first
found out about marijuana.
When I first,
when I first,
when I was a kid,
I thought marijuana was bad for you,
made you stupid,
all these different things.
But when I first stArted smoking weed,
the thing that fascinated me the most
was that there are two completely
different strains that have very
different effects.
Just different string.
Okay.
Let me break this down.
can I say this right now?
There's a lot of confusion in this.
Before I went to prison,
a friend of mine,
he wrote marijuana,
botany and he later wrote the book has
been revised.
HIs name's robert carnal clock.
He's forgotten more about cannabis and
I've had an opportunity to learn.
And um,
while I was in prison,
these scientists actually looked at the
specimens of sativa and indica and
sativa and indica where questions.
So if I walked up to you at seeds,
joe,
it would actually be.
Does this make clothing and paper and
all this stuff?
Or is it like India?
Because there's,
if you look up the word endeca,
endeca means of.
Or like India.
Okay.
So when you go to India,
all of the cannabis that's grown there
is endeca because it's in India.
But when you go there,
you'll find tropical varieties down by
goer and northern varieties up by the
area that's now Pakistan and hindu kush.
That is the entire range of cannabis.
And it's all indycar history.
Lesson is interesting,
but either everyone today who wants pot,
there's two different effects in tacoma.
Makes you sleepy and it makes you couch
weed.
It makes you what a lot of people think
of as a stoner.
Sativa is a totally different experience
and it makes you much more introspective
and makes you start looking at fucking
telescopes and space documentaries.
So let me,
let me saY strain.
What should we call it?
Well,
it's an equatorial variety.
It's from near the equator because.
Let me break this down.
There's two different effects though.
Correct?
And this is what I want people not pot
smokers to understand this.
When you go into these deep historical,
it's not but,
but definitely in the sixties and
seventies,
all the pot that was coming into America
was acapulco,
gold,
michu,
ican,
molly wiley,
jamaican.
All of these strange were the equator
tropical.
They made you hoppi,
horny,
well organized,
wanting to do things like protests,
and then the hippies went to
Afghanistan.
They found this short fat leaves plant
that they thought was endeca and they
started mixing it with all these
tropical varieties like maui wowie and
thai stick and stuff,
and they shortened the time it takes to
flower cannabis and they picked
varieties that yielded the most amount
of pot because it isn't being
the ones that were ecuadorian.
The ones that were growing on the
equator needed a longer cycle of sun
because it's right,
because they're in a 12,
12 and those are the ones
that have the different psychoactive
effect.
The ones that come in contact more with
the sun or the ones that make
not so much more with the sun.
It's just the varieties that develop
near the equator where there was a
longer cycle are more innocent psycho
and in a sense in America they have to
be grown indoors.
Yep.
And then what happened is the hippies in
a sense,
started breeding this afghan with all of
their tropical varieties and through the
eighties we kind of developed this one
hit wonder pot that took away all that
good energy and took away all that.
And now for me,
I always smoke haze.
I like super silver haze and then a five
by what people don't understand what
you're saying,
haze mean sativa in a sense.
It Does in the sense our terminology of
sativa,
but sativa really means most useful.
Okay.
The way.
Okay,
that's true.
But what's that's not how it's used in
dispensary's,
indycar and sativa is how it's used.
Sativa is the heady more trippy space.
We'd and endeca is
couch high energy.
My whole point in the beginning was I
did not know there was two different
types of pot.
I thought pat was pot and then all pod
had a similar effect.
Some pot maybe stronger than other pond,
but it's basically all pot.
You're going to smoke pot,
you leave get really high or what,
but it's not the same.
It's not even remotely the same.
There are two different experiences and
almost everyone is used to India because
India [inaudible] the easiest shit to
grow and because the shit that you're
getting,
if you're getting it from some dudes are
coming down from Canada,
growing
brick weed that grows the fastest and us
the most.
And now that we're getting through
prohibition will see these varieties
that take longer and yield less,
but have a profoundly different effect
on our energy and our thinking.
And so how is it wrong?
What I was saying,
well it's not sativa,
everybody's calling it sativa,
but sativa really means hemp.
It's indo european hemp derived.
Right?
But we've decided we haven't named what,
what,
what everyone.
Universally,
in the pot community,
they're looking at two different things
into and sativa.
That's what they called it,
right?
That's as universally in the poc
community.
They're all just annoys you.
Make with your mouth.
Had described something.
Absolutely different noise soon.
We're not going to call it sativa and
indica once we went.
No,
no,
no.
Right now we look,
we call reality.
California's not that lead and coach.
We'd,
what do we call it?
We'll call it names like,
you know,
arrowhead or you know,
avi on or whatever.
We're calling that water at the time.
We don't really go get me a bottle of
water when we're sitting in a five star
restaurant.
We say,
do you have and to do you have bottled
water?
What am I a fucking water kind of sore
and now I just want water.
Okay,
now trip on this the same way right now.
You walk up to a week counter,
it's almost like the same thing because
you can't make distinguishes like you do
liquor and when you walk up to a bar,
you know the difference between wine and
whiskey and if somebody you ought to
whiskey and they hand you wine,
you're going to be like,
yo douche bag.
This isn't what I asked for.
But when I go to the store I say,
hey,
where's your sativas?
Oh,
we got jack cleaner.
We got train regard.
Give me some of that train wreck.
I mean that's the way we do,
but technically all drug varieties are
endeca.
What?
No,
there's two different types that when
you go to indicate when you go to India
and you get into and it's going to suck
my dick.
There's two different experiences.
We're still good as data people don't
know.
Look,
practical knowledge is very important.
What all he's saying is all nonsense.
There's two different experiences.
There's the couch weed and there's the
weed that makes you think about the
universe and want to be creative.
So that's sativa.
That's what they call it.
The endeca shit is oji kush,
you know,
I'm going to take a nap and eat cheetos
all day.
Oh gee.
Grows very much like a sativa just so
you know.
It's long and leggy and grows tall and a
small buds and the different.
It's a more version of the event.
I know.
It's weird.
My,
my hayes,
my sativa you're calling it came back at
23 point seven thc and my oji cushion.
Dukkha.
It came back at 20 point six.
There was a three point one.
Differences.
There are a bunch of different things
canabinoids other than thc that make up
the high.
It's not just thc.
Well actually I think that um,
there was a doctorate and by the way,
we should point out that todd knows his
shit.
Where's your book?
Like,
who is this?
God?
Well,
there was a doctor.
What does he know?
This is what he knows,
bitch.
He's got a book how to grow medical
marijuana out of europe.
Oh,
I'm right here.
No,
I came back.
It's on a delay.
This is a a book how to grow medical
marijuana and it's not.
It's not in print right now.
Right now to get it.
You go to amazon.com
and maybe get a used copy.
YEs,
probably do that right on my next book.
Grow.
Medicine's going to come out and I'm
going to be talking about
strain.
Specific growing.
Yeah.
You could write a lot of books on
growing wheat.
It's very complex,
isn't it?
It is,
and there's a lot of differences when
people try to say,
oh,
generalized is how you grow pot.
You can tell they've never grown pot
because pot is very different to grow.
I mean,
go ahead.
I was going to say,
this is a question I need answered
because I do not understand it.
Now the there's a female plant and a
male plant and you need the female plant
is where the medicine comes from.
Where we come from,
right?
they're both right,
but.
But they become one or the other,
like you have to get the males out.
Explain what happens,
like how it pollinates sales or sex,
much like men in in an irony,
you'll find fun.
Normal with other plants.
By the way,
some plants are either dioecious or have
both sexes on one plant.
Cannabis actually can be both because it
doesn't matter night and sometimes fuse
on it.
So you get a mail,
you got to get it out of there.
Right?
Males actually create their pollen sac
faster than the females actually develop
their butts.
And in hemp,
for instance,
the males pollinate and then die off
early.
And the roman catholic church
miscategorized the male and female
plants,
even though the female had the seeds and
even though the male blue,
the pollen,
they didn't like that.
The male died off early.
so they called the male,
the female and the female to male.
Yeah,
they were heavy.
They were heavy into their dogma.
You know,
can't,
can't rattle their cage.
That's the way cannabis where,
how do you tell?
So if you grow and see if she'd grown a
bunch of weed plants,
you have to keep an eye on them bitches
because if they all,
they're all males just like certain
leaves,
like little tiny.
It's not all these.
What they do is they develop these
little,
they developed these little male pollen
sacks,
if you will.
And what they do is they come off the
flower different.
They come off the plant and they kinda,
they hang like little ball sacs and they
open up and then the,
then the,
then the pollen.
This is a male flower open.
The pollen is carried to the.
If you've ever seen the little red hairs
on your pot,
those are the sex glands and they are to
hire at all what the red.
The red hair doesn't get you higher at
all.
The red hair doesn't have crystals on,
you know,
they just had these cool though.
So you get some weed and you're like
that red hair scott.
Doesn't matter what you want.
Yeah.
And it's funny because it's so pretty,
but when that male pollen hits those
pistols,
what it does is it causes that to
fertilize in the seed,
grows in that little pod and if she
doesn't get fertilized,
that pod just scoot swells and swells
and swells and the resin develops
deeper.
That's why we grow seedless cannabis
because it's like tricking the female
into like really producing a lot of
residents and a lot of,
you know,
just she's waiting and waiting and
waiting to be fertilized.
It never comes.
So it makes it more potent.
Well,
you know,
potency I think is an interesting
conversation.
There was a doctor at the institute of
medicine who got up one day and he said,
I gave my patients 10 milligrams thc and
they had a known effect and then they
gave him 10 milligrams thc in one
milligram cbn and it doubled the
effective dose.
And I shot my hand up and I said,
hey,
would that replicate in nature?
And he said,
I think it would.
And when I put my hand down,
my publisher said,
what did you two geeks just asking each
other?
And I said,
basically he told me to breed hemp in
with my drug varieties because cbn for
instances,
a chemical that's mostly found in hemp
and as we have bread away from the
characteristics of these equity,
loreal varieties that are more hemp,
like,
uh,
we have actually bred more towards the
drug varieties and we've lowered the
chemical of cbn down while raising the
up with less of an effective rate.
So now we have thc levels over 20
percent that wouldn't,
that don't hit us as hard as I believe
is if we had a little bit of cbn mixed
in with it.
How many different cannabinoids are
there inside a marijuana plant?
Um,
well,
there are over 400 chemicals created by
the cannabis plant.
And that's the definition of a
cannabinoid.
And uh,
the reality is,
is that 60 of them are known to be
therapeutic or your shit's vibrate.
It's okay.
We'll ignore it.
It was coming through the microphone.
And,
uh,
and what's going to happen is that as
science understands these elements of it
more than they'll be able to better
direct what the different chemicals.
And alSo terpene,
because terpenes are these volatile oils
that are on the bud and what happens is
they're kind of steamed off when it's
dried.
So if anybody's ever picked up a
cannabis flower and it had good body and
you squished it and had studied moisture
and you could smell it was real strong.
Those turpines were intact anD even that
has a psychoactive effect.
It's very much an a synergistic
psychoactive effects.
So it's good.
It's good.
Overdrawing it bad job because likes to
take his weed and put it on the heater.
I put that shit on a year to make
joints.
I put that shit on the window sill.
Let it dry out.
Yeah,
perfect.
I put it.
Sometimes I put it on top of the tv,
but the reality is is because a lot of
what he's getting is people that are
hurrying to market and they sell pot
that's not dry and not cured.
The best cannabis is actually not just
dried but cured and then stored for
about three months and then see oil set
up and they're the smoothest.
Yes.
And then there's a window of when those
cannabinoids actually keep themselves,
which is between three months and nine
months.
So after nine,
after nine months,
you,
we'd starts to degrade,
chemically decompose in a sense.
Yes.
So old weeds,
whack,
whatever.
What about if you cook different,
how about different,
what have you cook with it?
We feel really good old chocolate bar,
an old chocolate bar.
How long does that last?
If you have an old we chocolate bar
older than nine months in the dairy
product and it will be moldy and you
have other issues with dark chocolate,
they're ramped up.
Well,
not the kind of pain is you have some of
those,
uh,
old fucking nestle's quik bars have they
made with wheat.
Uh,
you know,
a lot of why I don't eat cannabis that's
provided to me by people is because I
don't know the conditions in which it's
made and they don't trust their,
you know,
the way they handled it and stuff.
And yet not Just measuring because you
don't know how strong it's going to be.
Interestingly enough,
you know in holland I'm like hash bond
bonds and brownies are considered a hard
drug.
Totally verboten.
Yeah.
You can be 16 and go into a dutch coffee
shop,
buy hash on your way to high school and
you cool.
You can't buy brownie that you told me
about first.
You're the first person to tell me about
11 hydroxy.
That eating we're eating.
We'd when you eat wheat,
it goes through your liver and kidneys
and it actually turns a chemical process
and it turns
the psychoactive chemical thc into
another chemical called 11 hydroxy
metabolite and that 11 hydroxy is two to
five times more psychoactive than the
canvas.
Actually it's three to five times was
the estimate I saw out of the uNiversity
of Mississippi and you don't get a thcv.
I mean a 11 hydroxy in your bloodstream
when you smoke cannabis.
It's so.
It's such a different experience and
you're definitely talking about it.
One night,
I don't remember what the context of the
conversation was,
but it was probably.
I ate something that was just too
fucking strong and you had to explain
it.
It's so many people have had it and
they're like,
it's a mama,
I'm on acid or something.
It does not feel like pot and you're not
used to it because when you smoke pot,
you're only used to dealing with thc in
your bloodstream and that to you and not
11 hydroxy front man,
nothing you should fear.
We were on a,
we were at a plane the other day.
We were flying to austin,
Texas and a rat ate a cookie in his car
on the way to the airport.
And then,
uh,
he got there and you know,
it takes an hour and 20 minutes or so to
kick in.
He got there.
We were on the plane,
on the tarmac and he was seriously
thinking about telling them that they
had to let him off the plane because
he's that high.
Oh no.
Until we landed some model,
did that.
The other day I saw dave chappelle did a
to a dave chappelle.
Had a panic moment on the plane.
I got to get off.
It might have been that,
you know,
that's one of those things that you
wonder if you really want to go.
I'll go with it though.
What if you get off the plane?
The plane crashed as you book.
Thank you baby.
Jesus.
I'm not religious.
No.
It would be a moment.
You know,
I guess parachutes high flux so it would
save george bush's father,
his parachute and the first draft of the
declaration of independence was drafted.
Him know motherfucker integral part of
our history men.
And this is why I'm trying to convince
people that you needed that had no other
options.
Canvas was the only thing they had.
There was no cotton gin when she knitted
the first american flag.
You know,
we,
we only need look at our history's time
table to realize what we were using
before the invention of some of these
things.
This is all lost information,
ladies,
gentlemen,
and if you want to find out more about
this,
if you're really fascinated,
go pick up this book.
The emperor wears no clothes.
It's a the one that,
as we said,
was written bar late friend jack herer
harris.
How you say right now?
I think terror.
Yeah.
Hara.
Like terry used to say,
you know,
was we'd still available to,
you know?
Yeah.
You can still buy a strain is a strain
named after him.
He is there a time.
Mccormick strain out there.
Thank god.
No,
no.
Thank god.
No god,
no.
There's a joe rogan out there.
I don't know.
I don't know where it is.
I was just going to say fuck it.
I'll give you permission to me,
man.
This is an officially sanctioned joe
rogan's train will be treated.
Were created by todd mccormick.
Do you want it or indicus tiva?
Fucking dope.
We just a sprinkle of endeca.
Sprinkle some time.
Makes you a little silly little
sprinkle.
I think that's a great idea.
I like to research and see what have
you.
Tried to put this together.
Thank you everybody for tuning into the
podcast.
Once again,
thank you to the flashlight for a
sponsored.
I don't know why I hold this up.
Can't just say it.
I can just say it,
but I feel like it's right here.
I have to show you that.
It's really does it light?
Is it like,
no,
there's no light.
There's no fucking fuck it.
Nobody's fucking smell this rubber.
Just shower.
Oh,
that's fucking weird,
reverend man.
You good man.
What's up with that?
I'll tell you what's up better for
masturbating.
Do you masturbate at all?
Don't lie.
Of course you do.
Right?
But if you masturbate,
why wouldn't you want one of these?
Because this is masturbation.
I could give you a long list of reasons.
It just popped right off my head leaning
in.
Dealing with.
This is how you deal with it,
right?
You open up the top,
So you shoot your load in there and then
you unscrew the bottom and then you
release the dishwasher.
That dish shuts your sign.
You're not getting that clean.
The top of it.
You shoot it.
Oh,
the load on your face.
You do whatever you want to shoot on
your face.
I like to think brian plays out with a
song.
What's the song?
Brian?
Walking on a dream by in.
Thank you everybody for tuning in.
We may or may not be doing one of these
on a thursday.
Maybe do it with joe and my website.
Send them to,
um,
empire media,
dotcom,
kampire.
That's what an h,
h,
m,
pir.
You can find him on twitter,
empire media.
The folks that aren't watching this
right now in the eu.
Uh,
ustream,
hampshire media on twitter,
hem p,
I r,
e media,
and of course brian is red band and I am
just my name joe rogan.
Thank you very much under section 200 in
may.
See you guys on thursday.
If not as always.
I love you bitches.